tee
うちは外れ社長ですありますよ多分かかとの骨が折れているんですよ
川に落ちた時に
こうぼく細いんでだから脱みたいだったんですよ
ダーツのまま川に入っちゃって深さは結構あったんですけど普通に一番下の岩にかかと
から刺さっちゃって
もう歩けないんですよ痛すぎて中には受けないんですけどが骨が折れた状態で今どこ
沿っております
パズル社長です漫談けっけっけなこの笑顔離脱とかな
なんとかなる理由がいく道ってやってくださあなぁ心配されて声も出ると思わなきゃね
ノート1本や描画なあんまりの機微しないから那覇別にいいんだけどさ
動くときはね
ずっとなんかたためで負傷して白に変える編集みたいな歩き方ですごい帰ってるんで
近いうちに病院に行ってきますまじ歩けない
4全北年に沖縄のユーチューバーだね一人二人と見に来たわけで沖縄独特の
なんかこのものを置いてたんでねほか沖縄に行きたいんだしたいけどあまり機器
被害はないんでねあいつらがねはいサイダーハイサイたい
ハイサイ探偵団って言うんだけどねまあそいつら置いてったら
沖縄のにこうなんか沖縄っぽい何かを3つねおいてたんでね今日は一個ずつ飲んで
いこう度食べていこうと思いますじゃあまずはこれなら
すぱふぇナースた6
スタッフダーワーブロック等応現8月は全員すためブロッカーこんな感じです
打ったことないんだよけどドンキで見たことあるかなぁ
沖縄沖縄で作られっていうのは知ってるけど食べたことないんだな
なんかこれ大丈夫そう3期限2017年までだ
ん
これは5
これがスタムかお子様だズっぽい風食べたいわけだなあこのまま食ってもいいんだよ
おい
キタキタキタキター
1 day 子
ポンッ
こんな感じです
か甘いないはあ
お肉の味がする
じゃあ次はこちらですね a & w root beer ということでこれどうな
のか
バニラ羽根バニラバナー作ってくれって普通の沖縄の人たち幕あんまり美味しくないっ
て言ってましたなぜねあんまり過度な期待をせずにそんな味だと思いますオープン
これ湿布の匂いがする ship ん良いだ
これやば本当にの面倒はこれならシップないようにする
皆さん覚えておいてくださいこれルートビアだいただきます
なんかなぁ嘘やん大きなはちょっとマンスですか
シップがすごいこれだけ接骨院音ですよはいよいや最後でございますこちらですね
コンビーフハッシュ沖縄ホーメルって会社で作られています
コンビーフハッシュを贈りますちょっと説明できんが
それか
パパ部を
数バーグがあまり上手に握れなかった感じでしただけます
た
別本当に廃材探偵のありがとうお土産を打ち勝った全体的に美味しかった
ルートビアも出府な耳にするけど美味しかった
まとめとしては言えば全体2位のまず目としてはかかとが痛い
ます
tee